[Music]
all right Oni I saw two top stories
former deputy assistant to the president
Fox News national security strategist
sebastian Gorka former Secret Service
agent NRA TV contributor Dan Mangino and
Fox News correspondent and at-large for
although Geraldo you're out manned and
and I'll start with you because of that
reason a gun
no no well but the thing is since you
agree with me you agree secure the
perimeter a full security assessment
every school armed retired concealed
carry police retired military here's the
problem you have when you go around the
military and you've been out with them
so they love you police in New York love
you
you have always fought for the the
people that defend our freedoms and
protect our communities I've never heard
of a cop ever not being so prepared that
they they want this is what the if they
that moment comes there they want to say
people why I think we have a tendency
though Shawn with all due respect and I
love cops and I love G is sometimes
idealize them cop Scott Peterson was by
all accounts a doughnut cop what I call
a Dunkin donut cop a cop who goes and
sits and has a belly and you know
doesn't do much and that when push comes
to shove you know one thing I found out
in all of my wartime assignments
you know 22 assignments in Iraq and
Afghanistan is that courage and
cowardice is decided in the blink of an
eye you never know how are you gonna
respond like the president said he would
charge indeed be invaded never he
doesn't really know you only know when
it's what does it have an incident that
we know about all right what I'm saying
is you know it happens you you either
chicken out will you charge in and you
are a hero a Medal of Honor where they
didn't ponder that and you we all have
but they are treated and mentally they
prepare for those moments that's what
they trained so hard for that's what the
investigation will reveal did this chief
of the Department of the the Broward
sheriff Israel did he have a protocol
that insisted to his officers as most
departments have since Columbine in 1999
there's a school active shooter in a
school you run to the
you don't wait for backup you don't wait
for the SWAT team you don't secure the
perimeter you go in and try to save the
children if you don't take out the
shooter then maybe you'll stop the
bleeding of one of the critically
injured children involved Bernie Kerik
them that protocol then Israel has to go
Bernie Kerik is a good friend of mine
and he ran a different department and
not on all right damn Bungie no you
worked in the Secret Service you've been
in the NYPD isn't this what every cop
trains for I've never heard of one never
mind
four and then you heard the comments of
Israel what do you think yeah well I
waited for a while to jump in in this
debate because I I'm pretty confident
Florida uses what they call the alert
system for school security and responses
to school shooting incidents and Shawn
that system I believe it involves
multiple deputies going in but here's
the distinction so I wasn't sure if it
was the deputy waiting for someone else
but once the report started to come out
that multiple deputies responded and
still didn't go in I just want to be
clear on this there is no response to
school violence I know of out there that
requires them not to go in set up a
perimeter and wait everybody post
Columbine is pretty much taught to
respond maximum to the problem right
away but if you have to plate away the
39 times are at this kids house or the
Baker Act notes from Florida would allow
them to institutionalize this kid Manan
case see something say something we had
every single sign symptom and evidence
that this was the guy doctor Gorka no
look I've said it before and I'll say it
again Shawn political correctness can
get people killed if these reports are
true that they weren't allowed to enter
the building because their body cameras
didn't work I've got a reminder for the
sheriff of Broward County Florida
Statute on sheriff's powers section 5
chapter 30 says the sheriff is
responsible for the negligence of his
deputies it's not just Columbine after
the past nightclub after San Bernardino
all Police Department's around the globe
are reassessing their protocols you
don't wait for the hostage negotiator
you don't secure the perimeter whether
you've got a hard plated vest in your
car or not whether you've got a long gun
doesn't matter you enter the building to
neutralize the threat that's the new
reality if this sheriff said don't go in
there because we need their body cams
switched on he must be forced out of
office or recalled I believe that to use
the expression negligence doctor Gorka
gives too much credit negligence this
was a person making a choice I hear
gunshots going off inside gunshots fired
gunshots fire gunshots fire and you sit
there or you hide behind a concrete the
arcade that's not negligence there is a
much I think the President had it right
that was a disgusting response to an
emergent situation this is a no brainer
you go in you go to the action you go
you die going over the the the berm go
and try and save a child put a
tourniquet on a kid take two ifs get
that arm do something do something do
anything other than protecting yourself
damn Bungie No yeah well listen Sean
this is more of a reason to allow
teachers to arm themselves if they're
willing point the arm god that was Scott
Peterson that's right that's exactly
right
wait wait wait but if the team what I'm
saying is if the teacher is there on the
scene immediately the cop had a respond
from across the campus it was a large
campus the teachers are right there you
know sometimes when you need law
enforcement in seconds they're minutes
away I mean unless this guy's an Olympic
sprinter I'm not absolving him listen he
clearly didn't burn a building he did
not go in the building
the teacher was already there to teach
the clothes on the action he should be
fired that there's an issue with this
question of arming teachers especially
if they're vets you don't have to be you
know a tier 1 operator or a classified
marksman where if there's one person in
the building who simply laying down fire
in the direction of the perpetrator
it's like it's much much harder to kill
people person have been armed if one
person had been out in San Bernardino we
might not have had 40 people
Gorka is you need guards on every floor
you need the perimeters secure you need
a full threat assessment security
assessment if we do that for every
school and we have the manpower and
they're on there on the floor they're in
the building that's where they should be
right totally agreed let's neutralize
that threat yeah all right thank you all
for being with us